now let's just slowly step out through
it because we're getting into a
different mother murdered for thinking
because Ruthenian finance for a little
time question brings down really with me
oranges are sold for $350 now poor sir
moon in the second we're gonna read
these two things these are the two
quantities that are related to each
other that's why it's called mini our
relationships right so we're always
gonna be looking at something versus
something else okay something and its
value depends on something that's
similar to it or related so the two
values we're interested here
ah-ha weight versus cost weight versus
so they ask us can you draw the graph of
weight versus cost so Part A this is
question 1 we're going to draw this okay
now when you have a look at this there's
two what we call variables right two
numbers that can change but they have
different um different names so you can
kind of see this in the second part
which is the dependent variable
okay so there's a number and it varies
changes and then there's another number
that changes and it depends on the other
one right so double you know what one
changes it makes the other one change it
drives the other one if you can kind of
see in the way that this is set up
weight is the thing that's independent
you can make the weight whatever you
like how many kilos should I buy I guess
I'm gonna buy me okay this is the
independent variable you can make it
whatever you like the cost depends on
how much you buy it depends on how many
kilos so that makes the cost the
dependent very okay you might write that
down
wait
is the independent variable
that means that you can change it
independently you can muck about it and
make it any value you choose right that
is the other thing dependent on this
okay so I'm going to say cost is the
dependent one because it depends on how
what weight you want
okay now you will not usually have to
write this out in length and it's only
because our first question we really try
to wrap our head around things so
therefore I want to make this like easy
for you to refer to as I know something
I guess one other way you can think
about it is that no one's going to go
and say like yeah I'd like three dollars
with the oranges please write their ask
in terms of cost you can ask in terms of
weight and then the cost just comes in
this side of it so now with your war
there we're going to draw a set of axes
now before we do this don't enjoy this
fun you're used to seeing sets of axes
like this yes now I want to point out a
couple of things here firstly we tend to
put the independent variable the one
that you can change we tend to put it on
the horizontal that's we tend to Jim
don't try this one render a new one of
the same things is something wrong with
this one
that means we put the other one the
dependent variable on the boat now I
want you to look closely at these
numbers that we actually have here right
because I've got weight going up here in
this and I've got the cost that also
goes up out of linear rate at the same
time do you notice you can't have
negative kilos of oranges right does
that make sense they're negative killers
like can you get to the shopping that
Kim I'm gonna sell you my oranges okay
therefore if this is the end of it let's
say the number of kilos of oranges right
you've got zero here and that goes 1 2 3
etc so this entire left-hand side of the
graph but do you agree it's kind of
gonna be meaningless in this situation
right he caught by negative killers she
actually don't want this part of the
graph does that make sense you can get
fed in that what else can I call this I
can cut the budget because you're not
going to get there the register
yes that would be here's five dollars
for this oranges you born right there's
no there's no sense in saying isn't
making part to the dependent variable
which is cost so now we're ready you can
draw your own set of X's now and we're
only going to throw on one because they
were for section C before
I'm divided up by the lines we call
these quadrants you only have to draw
one of the quadrants and just this one
which has the positive values doesn't do
that
Oh happy do we want it okay so I give
for what's in your watch my general
guideline is the size of your pot so
look at hand on your hand size of your
palm
okay so you see how make your mom is
right I don't think any grabs should be
any smaller than that okay I see a lot
of 50 cent coin size graphs in by in my
profession and it too small you can't
read anything off that when you get the
HSC we'll talk about this in more detail
later on when you get the edge you see
that except you draw an even bigger
write like this is like the bare minimum
as a person or that he looks enormous on
my page so if you can omit put your here
and put in your graph and then people
okay that's about the space I wanted to
take up that'll give you an education
okay
it's roughly it's your blog fit on the
page okay so we've got a couple of axes
here remember I said we tend to put the
independent variable which we have a
main ports weight we tend to put it on
this horizontal axis
up so you can either you can put it down
here if you like you can label it down
you'll see graphs that do that but I'm
trying to remember back to when you did
like we're going to support geometry
right you labeled I usually call this
bless you
X&Y put them up an endless right
sometimes we won't be able to put them
down here because we have all this stuff
happening there there will be some grass
roots like why what negatives because
I've got like tipper jump Canada right
or whatever it's Jeff and so do you help
the first place ahead big iconic are
therefore put a label down because my
graph is gonna go right through them
okay so I think that's a safe spot
there's way how I should put the unit's
as well so this is and then I have cost
in dollars that is my vertical axis my
dependent right now in order to put this
on and make sure it's accurate I need to
just look at these numbers right and
make sure that I put like I don't want
to put markings on here and then put
like one to twenty four or five six
they're all bad and it's like all the
way I have finishes okay so look at how
why do you make that maybe minutes 60
minutes maybe 10 something like that
I'm the way that I would cheat it to is
that when you are in a pinch and you try
to make sure that it's roughly accurate
right you just go as far as you can go
and say that's my end point so for
instance for me not having our Google
right now I'm gonna put six dams then
I'm gonna say well it's easy
everyone can pretty accurately visually
it's something quite simply so for me
half looks like it's about there and now
from there I just need to fill in a
couple of spots that evenly divide into
the thirds and arrow my numbers right
I don't know if you guys remember Thomas
or how to draw that 12 I said drive
around the clock I'm kind of doing that
so goofy obviously if you have a rule I
have lots more numbers you may want to
just mention round like bit even
intervals you often will have a great
book and that's fun